1/6th of all Google searches have never been
searched before.
When you suck on hard candy you are basically
drinking your own saliva mixed with flavourings.
Hitler's handwriting was impeccable. When
famous psychologist Carl Jung saw hitler's
handwriting he noted that Hitler's handwriting
suggests that he has highly feminine instincts.
Only 1% of a tree is actually alive. The other
99% is hardened, dead cells.
$1.2 trillion of US money is in circulation,
but nobody knows where 85% of it is.
The ice lost in Antarctica every year would
be enough to give every person on Earth 1,360,000
ice cubes.
It is possible to travel by zip wire from
Spain to Portugal.
Vegetables are roughly four times healthier
than fruit.
Sweden is so good at recycling that they've
run out of rubbish and import 80,000 tonnes
a year from Norway. In fact, Sweden even recycles
dead rabbits into biofuel.
You are four times more likely to drown in
your bath than you are to die of food poisoning.
In 17th-century Virginia, missing three Sunday
Masses in a row carried the death penalty.